au moins un tigre 2 au new york est
attendue coronavirus fort probablement
contaminé par un gardien asymptomatiques
il aurait possiblement effectifs
plusieurs de ses congénères
les ennemis ne sont pas en danger mais
leur cas soulève une question pour tous
les propriétaires de félins petit ou
grand peuvent-ils vraiment rappelle
coronavirus et surtout peuvent-ils
également nous le transmettre
on a déjà eu des codes changent en
belgique un autre à hong kong qui ont
été porteurs donc c'est pas surprenant
qu'une étude toute récente sur
différents animaux va dans le même sens
on constate que le virus se propage
facilement chez les chats et les furets
mais beaucoup moins chez les chiens il
pas du tout chez le porc le poulet et le
canard en général les conséquences chez
les mâles infectés sont peu importantes
dont on parle de perte d'appétit petits
problèmes respiratoires est bon ça
s'estompe en a pas de mortalité mais si
coronavirus qui affecte les humains est
capable d'infecter aussi des chats et
des furets linverse ne semble pas
possible
ce qui est surtout important de dire
c'est que les shows même s'ils sont
porteurs ont la maladie ne peuvent pas
la retransmettre à un humain menace qui
peuvent leur transmettre à d'autres
shows cdh à l'étude c'est à vérifier
pour l'instant noir n'est pas de preuve
pour les propriétaires d'animaux de
compagnie il faut quand même rappeler
que le poil de nêne mal comme n'importe
quelle surface pu servir de moyen de
transport au virus
si vous prenez une marche avec votre
chien mais clairement ni les trajets
devrait pas toucher à l'animal ici vous
êtes porteur
peut-être vous isoler un petit peu de
l'animal ce pôle temps de le caresser
des bio n'est dilbeek vous m nage en
eaux de pièces puis bon quand votre car
athènes doit être terminée vous allez
guéri le chat ou le chien ne seront plus
portant accidentelle
puis tout devrait bien rentré dans
l'ordre ici normand grondin radio canada
montréal